huh i love the way you think
i wasn't good
i think they should have like uh in the
blues brothers they had the chicken wire
up you know on the club
invest in chicken wire yeah for the
stand-up community bring your own
chicken wire cage when you do stand up
this is better than nfts
i'm telling you chicken wire insecurity
yeah is where you got to put your money
lock it all down people listen to this
podcast for input on uh business on
cryptocurrency investing are you guys in
cryptocurrency are you in cryptocurrency
no no no no you i barely actually i'm
i'm making an episode for vice news
right now on it but it's like i don't
understand it it's so confusing
that's what it's about it's just me for
me to learn things and then i put out a
video yeah you we eric and i last year
when nfts just started bubbling up as a
thing we didn't understand it but
someone reached out to us like you can
make good money and you've got all this
stuff and you could own your own art and
all that crap
and uh so we this guy set it up for us
and we're like i i'd read a couple
things was a little iffy about it a
little confused and then we did it we we
did one
are you gonna throw up
just thinking about the experience
we did one you're gagging and
within right away
it was like ding ding ding people like
no no no no this is the how could you
this is i hate this not you not you guys
sellouts
and we just tank we just killed it right
away
because it was so much more it was hard
because i read about it and i thought it
was all i think it's all junk i still do
um
but i think it's a scam but
we tried the scam and we realized that i
think the perception
of for us is way more valuable than
whatever monetary gain
even if it's some of its like overblown
billion
what what about what if it was a billion
well there's always a number doug
there's always a there's always a cash
out number right
but yeah i mean it just felt like the
perception at least and some of it's
true some of it's not but the perception
from our audience who are very cool
liberal
woke
people a lot of the time
was that this wasn't
a good thing to be involved with and so
we just [ __ ] bailed it was just like
somebody else can we don't have to do
all these things you know right
but too much to really even absorb and
understand i kind of get the appeal
though where it's it's somebody
explained to me as like baseball cards
like i had baseball basketball cards
growing up and everything so
you just put a value on it's just you
know cardboard or whatever but people
are paying thousands of dollars for it
so it's
i understand i i sort of get it i sort
of get it i do get it yeah you got it i
do do you think it's a pump and dump
kind of thing where it's like do you
know garyvee is yeah of course okay
cause like i saw this like story of him
where he
he brought up or he he called all his
riches friends and said i'm selling v
bucks or whatever they are and all these
billionaires bought it and then
eventually they you know they said they
talk about it to their friends and
everything and then they get out of it
sell it and then they cash out but then
there's all these like little i think it
depends
kind of thing well in anything there's
going to be corruption there's going to
be abuse in anything but what was always
funny about crypto and
you'd have these guys be like this is
the one thing that's not that that they
can't control or that you you know like
this is this the exception to the rule
and that always felt disingenuous but
that's uh you know it's the same as just
a regular stock market things like that
too speculative yeah it's always it's
gambling right and gambling and it's a
game and life is a game and you guys uh
seem to be playing the game pretty well
we are the masters of the game you are
the master
[Music]
you